eight-month-old baby among the injured
in a Russian missile attack that hit a
chromatosk pizza restaurant about 20
kilometers inside the Ukrainian side of
the front line no no you heard if you
can hear us more than 50 people were
injured among the dead Anna and Yulia
axonchenko twins who would have turned
15 in September
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielenski
said it's another example of Russian
Terror
the Kremlin said its airstrike hit a
temporary Ukrainian Army command post
Russian military
not attacking civilian infrastructure
Kiev zelenski welcomed two of his
closest allies for Ukraine Poland's
Andrei Duda and lithuania's Gitana
noseda both want Ukraine admitted to
Nato as soon as possible a view shared
by many NATO countries bordering Russia
we need to send a strong message of Hope
to the Ukrainian soldiers in the
trenches that with NATO membership on
the horizon they are fighting their last
war with Russia NATO Chief Jens
stoltenberg a little more measured ahead
of next month's NATO Summit I think it's
too early to
pre-announce the outcome of the winner
Summit in Russia the Moscow times
reports that Sergey sarovkin a former
commander of Russia's Invasion has been
arrested earlier the New York Times said
U.S intelligence believed he knew in
advance about Evgeni pregozian's
attempted Mutiny there is 10 perhaps a
split within the Russian military
establishment with some commanders who
have been close to rigosian that
Rebellion cracked the foundations of
Vladimir Putin's Authority something
healing to repair before it might
collapse Redmond Shannon Global News
London